meilenstein in der energieforschung sind
bald schon alle energieprobleme der
menschheit gelöst experten des
max-planck-instituts für plasmaphysik
uhr cpb haben in mecklenburg vorpommern
eine million grad heißes plasma im
reaktor erzeugt was bedeutet das für uns
menschen klicks um science-fiction
am vergangenen donnerstag ist in
greifswald gigantisches gelungen die
kern forschungsanlage wendelstein 7-x
verzeichnete einen meilenstein in der
energieforschung die forscher des
max-planck-instituts für plasmaphysik
haben in einer vakuumkammer zehn
milligramm helium für rund eine
zehntelsekunde auf eine temperatur von
rund einer million grad celsius gebracht
dadurch ist ein extrem heißes und
dichtes heliumgas main standen mit
diesem plasma könnte man in zukunft auf
der erde eine kleine künstliche sonne
betreiben
bei diesen hohen temperaturen kommt es
zu einer kernfusion zwei atomkerne
verschmelzen hier zu einem neuen kern
auf der sonne passiert dass die ganze
zeit bei 15 millionen grad celsius und
dabei wird sehr viel energie freigesetzt
so viel das was hier auf der haut spüren
können und genau wie ihr großes portal
könnte eine künstlich geschaffene
kernfusion gewaltige mengen an energie
erzeugen allerdings herrscht auf der
sonne auch eindruck von 200 milliarden
baht
zum vergleich auf uns lastet im schnitt
eindruck von einem bar
deswegen muss die temperatur für eine
irdische kernfusion viel viel höher sein
100 millionen grad celsius müssen es
sein und am vergangenen donnerstag
konnten die forscher aber nahezu
unmögliches möglich machen
sie erzeugten in dem ringförmigen
reaktor ein plasma das entsteht wenn
sich die elektronen unter der hitze aus
ihren schalen lösen vom atomkern lösen
dieses plasma ist der erste schritt zu
einer kernfunktion in der
forschungsanlage wendelstein 7-x wurde
innerhalb von neun jahren eine riesige
apparatur aufgebaut der kostenpunkte
anlage liegt bei rund achtung festhalten
einer milliarde euro und sie wiegt
stolze 750 tonnen also ein auto das vieh
zu rund eine tonne
hier sehen wir wieder reaktor aufgebaut
wird und was genau gehört denn zu einer
solchen anlage dazu wie wird eine solche
temperatur erzeugt der wendelstein 7-x
anlage heizen sogenannte mikrowellen
heizung also wie eine mikrowelle zu
hause nur viel viel stärker die helium
atome auf millionen grad heißen solche
kann man verständlicherweise nicht mit
einfachen materialien an ort und stelle
halten dazu wird um die 16 meter im
durchmesser große röhre ein magnetfeld
erschaffen und die spulen in denen das
magnetfeld kreiert wird hier sehen wir
übrigens den aufbau müssen stark
heruntergekühlt werden damit
supraleitung entsteht fast bis zum
absoluten nullpunkt minus 270 grad
celsius und mit hilfe dieses feldes wird
das erhitzte plasma hier waren es zehn
milligramm helium die eben eine million
grad heiß geworden sind festgehalten und
von der wand weg gehalten
die teilchen rotieren dann in den ring
der anlage und durch den aufprall der
teilchen soll es dann zur kernfusion
kommen um tatsächlich energie hier auf
der erde gewinnen zu können müsste es
den forschern auch noch gelingen einige
ungewollte effekte abzuschaffen können
sich zum beispiel teilchen von den
wänden des ringens lösen und das plasma
verunreinigen
wenn es gelingt das zu verhindern und
einige andere probleme zu lösen ist die
energiegewinnung ein problem von gestern
das klingt jetzt alles nach weit
entfernte zukunftsmusik
forscher sehen das aber in nicht allzu
weiter ferne der direktor des gp
petronas klinger beschreibt den
erlangten erfolg so mit helium ist der
plasma zustand leichter zu erreichen
außerdem können wir mit helium plasmen
die oberfläche des plasma gefäßes
reinigen das zitat ende das ist jetzt
passiert wie weit sind wir also von
einer tatsächlichen kernfusion entfernt
klinger nennt den stand der dinge zitat
die erzeugung des helium placements ist
unsere gene
zitat ende für die stromgewinnung im
großen stil wäre der reaktor kreis wald
zwar zu klein aber zur forschung würde
er sich durchaus eignen
ein einziges gramm das bei der fusion
freigesetzt wird könnte forschern
zufolge 90.000 kilowattstunden energie
liefern über zehn tonnen kohle müsste
man dafür in kohlekraftwerken verheizen
ja das klingt wirklich vielversprechend
vielversprechend sind auch die anderen
vorteile der kern fusionsreaktoren
gegenüber kohlekraftwerken oder
kernspaltung reaktoren also herkömmlich
mit kernkraftwerken eine kernfusion ist
wesentlich ungefährlicher als eine
kernspaltung es wird auch radioaktives
material erzeugt aber bei weitem nicht
so viel wie bei der kernspaltung
außerdem hat der müll eine sehr kurze
halbwertszeit und ist nach rund 12
jahren ungefährlich es kann auch keine
kettenreaktion wie in fukushima geben
wenn etwas passiert hört einfach die
reaktion auf es entsteht jedoch
neutronenstrahlung die muss mithilfe
dicke betonwände abgeschirmt werden
klarer vorteil gegenüber der
kohleverbrennung ist die effizienz der
anlage aber auch der co2 ausstoß sinkt
gibt es nämlich nicht und nahezu
einziges problem bei den kern
fusionsreaktoren der kostenpunkt wählen
uns allein an die baukosten dieses
reaktors eine milliarde euro ist
kernfusion also die zukunft der
energieversorgung wird es bald möglich
sein kernfusion wirtschaftlich zu nutzen
fallen euch gegenargumente 1 klingt das
vielleicht alles zu phantastisch lasst
uns in den kommentaren drüber
diskutieren nicht vergessen nächstes
video schauen abonnieren ist kostenlos
und bis dann bleibt dran